En los últimos videos hemos estudiado cómo
encontrar el área de un triángulo y también vimos
la relación entre las áreas de los triángulos.
¿Recuerdas? En uno de los videos pasados
trabajamos con tres teoremas que relacionan
las áreas entre los triángulos, entonces lo
que haremos en este video será demostrar con
detalle estos tres teoremas para que quede más
claro de dónde salen. Veremos que no son magia o
sólo ideas que salieron de la nada, así que vamos
a hacerlo. Recordemos que el primer teorema decía
que: si cortamos uno de los lados de un triángulo
por una ceviana que pase por el punto -no sé- a
y que corte el lado bc, entonces puedes ver que
se formarán dos áreas: A₁ y A₂. Recuerda que una
ceviana es una recta que corta uno de los lados de
un triángulo y que pasa por el vértice opuesto.
Además podemos ver que el lado queda dividido
en dos secciones, que llamaremos m y n, entonces,
lo que decía el teorema uno que vimos en el video
pasado, es que las áreas y los lados cumplían
la siguiente relación: el A₁/m = A₂/n, y claro,
en el dado caso de que la ceviana sea una mediana,
entonces se tenía que el A₁ era igual al A₂. Bien,
por otra parte, el segundo teorema nos dice que:
si tenemos dos triángulos que tienen un ángulo
con la misma longitud, entonces la relación de sus
áreas y sus lados cumplía la siguiente relación:
el área A entre el área B es igual a la longitud
b por la longitud c entre la longitud n por la
longitud ñ (A/B = bc/nñ), en donde b y c son los
lados del triángulo que forman el ángulo en común
que tiene área A, mientras que n y ñ son los lados
del triángulo que forman el mismo ángulo pero
que tiene un área de B. Por último, estudiamos un
tercer teorema que decía que: en el caso de tener
triángulos semejantes, se cumplía la siguiente
relación entre las áreas y los lados: el área A
entre el área B es igual al lado a, al cuadrado,
entre el lado m, al cuadrado, que es igual al lado
b, al cuadrado, entre el lado n, al cuadrado, que
es igual al lado c, al cuadrado, entre el lado ñ,
al cuadrado (A/B = a²/m² = b²/n² = c²/ñ²). Así que
empecemos con la demostración del primer teorema.
El primer teorema nos dice que, si cortamos uno
de los lados de un triángulo por una ceviana,
es decir, una recta que corta uno de los lados
del triángulo y que pasa por el vértice opuesto
-que puede ser ésta o ésta o ésta otra- y con esto
se formarán dos áreas: A₁ y A₂, y, el lado opuesto
queda dividido en dos secciones, que llamaremos m
y n. Entonces se cumple la siguiente relación: A₁
/m = A₂/n. ¿Cómo demostramos que esta relación en
efecto es cierta? Pausa el video y piénsalo. Pero
antes te daré una pista: observa que la altura
de los dos triángulos que se forman es la misma.
Bien, vamos a trabajar juntos. Para comparar
estas dos áreas, A₁ y A₂, primero vamos a
calcularlas de manera habitual: el área de un
triángulo se calcula como b*h/2, ¿cierto? Bueno,
esa es una forma de calcularla; entonces el
A₁ es igual a su base, que sabemos que es m,
por su altura, que nombraremos h₁/2. Por su parte,
el A₂ es igual a su base, que sabemos que es n,
por su altura, que nombraremos h₂/2. Ahora bien,
podemos ver que la altura de este primer triángulo
es la misma altura que este segundo triángulo,
que a su vez es la misma altura que el triángulo
abc que pasa por a, ya que ésta es la única
recta perpendicular abc que pasa por a. Como
las tres alturas comienzan en a, deben de ser la
misma, entonces si h₁ = h₂, dicho de otra manera,
si despejamos a h₁ de la primera fórmula nos
quedará que h₁ es igual a dos veces el A₁ entre m,
y si despejamos h₂ de la segunda fórmula, tenemos
que h₂ es igual a dos veces el A₂ entre n;
pero si h₁ = h₂, entonces tenemos que 2 veces
el A₁ entre m es igual a 2 veces el A₂ entre n,
o si multiplicamos por ½ cada lado para cancelar
ambos doses, nos quedaremos con el A₁ / m = A₂ /
n, que es justo lo que queríamos demostrar. Así
que ya está, lo hemos logrado. Es ésta la razón
o justificación que hace que el teorema uno sea
cierto siempre, siempre. Observa que no es magia,
simplemente siguiendo estos pasos y al darnos
cuenta de que la altura es la misma para los
dos triángulos, podemos obtener la expresión que
buscamos. Ahora bien, imagínate que la ceviana
corte a la mitad al lado bc, es decir, sea la
mediana del lado bc, entonces en este caso m = n,
¿cierto?, ya que corta en dos partes iguales al
lado bc. En este caso tendremos que el A₁ = A₂,
ya que en la expresión A₁ / m = A₂ / n, m y n
son iguales. Muy bien, hemos demostrado el primer
teorema. Ahora nos queda más claro por qué es útil
esta expresión que compara las áreas de estos dos
triángulos que se obtienen de una ceviana o
una mediana del triángulo abc. Ahora veamos
cómo podemos demostrar el siguiente teorema.
El segundo teorema que estudiamos en el video
pasado nos dice que si tenemos dos triángulos que
tienen un ángulo con la misma longitud, es decir,
este ángulo es igual a este otro ángulo en
el otro triángulo, entonces, la relación
de sus áreas y sus lados cumple la siguiente
relación: el área A entre el área B = bc/nñ,
donde b y c son los lados del triángulo con área
A que, entre ellos, forman el ángulo en común,
mientras que n y ñ son los lados del triángulo
con área B que, entre ellos, forman el mismo
ángulo. ¿Cómo podemos demostrar esta expresión?
Pausa el video y piénsalo; pero antes te voy a
dar otra pista: utiliza la expresión del área
de un triángulo que dice que: A = bc/2 sen (α).
Bien, es momento de trabajar juntos, y como
prometimos, ¿qué te parece si utilizamos la
forma de encontrar el área de un triángulo que nos
dice que el A = bc/2 sen (α)? Bueno hagámoslo para
estos dos triángulos. Para el primero, tenemos que
el área de este triángulo, que hemos llamado A,
es igual a: A = bc/2 sen (α). Observa que tanto
b como c son los lados que forman el ángulo
alfa. Perfecto, hagamos lo mismo para el segundo
triángulo, y tengamos mucho cuidado con los datos
que tenemos. El área de este segundo triángulo,
que hemos llamado B, es igual a: B = nñ/2 sen (α).
Exacto, de nuevo por el seno de alfa porque este
es el ángulo que tiene la misma longitud en los
dos triángulos, es decir, estos dos ángulos son
iguales, ¿recuerdas? De nuevo, observa que n y ñ
son los lados que forman el ángulo alfa en este
triángulo. ¿Qué te parece si despejamos al seno
de alfa de ambas expresiones de área? Entonces
nos quedará que, en la expresión del área A,
el sen (α) = 2A/bc, mientras que en la expresión
del área B tendremos que el sen (α) = 2B/nñ,
es decir, 2A/bc = 2B/nñ, o, si cancelamos el 2
en ambos lados del mismo modo que en el teorema
anterior, tendremos que el área A/bc = al área
B/nñ. Ahora, agrupemos los valores del área de un
mismo lado de la expresión: si multiplicamos todo
por bc y dividimos todo por el área B, entonces,
del lado derecho, bc se cancela con bc y del lado
izquierdo el área B se cancelará con el área B;
entonces nos quedará que el área A entre el área B
= bc/nñ, que es justo lo que queríamos demostrar.
Es decir, usando la fórmula del área de un
triángulo, que nos dice que el A = bc/2 sen (α),
pudimos obtener que, para los dos triángulos,
los cuales tienen un ángulo de la misma longitud,
se cumple la siguiente relación entre sus áreas
y sus lados, y queda demostrado. Por último, pero
no por eso menos importante, hablemos del tercer
teorema que trabajamos en el video pasado, el cual
nos dice: si tenemos dos triángulos semejantes,
entonces se cumple la siguiente relación entre
las áreas y los lados: el área A entre el área
B = al lado a² entre el lado m², que es igual
al lado b² entre el lado n², que a su vez es igual
al lado c² entre el lado ñ². ¿Cómo podemos probar
estas relaciones entre los lados y las áreas?
Pausa el video y piénsalo. En esta ocasión
también te daré una pista: recuerda la relación
entre los lados de los triángulos semejantes.
Bien, trabajemos juntos. Dos triángulos son
semejantes si sus ángulos internos son iguales,
es decir, si este ángulo será igual a este ángulo,
este otro ángulo será igual a este otro ángulo, y,
por último, este ángulo será igual a este otro.
Además sabemos cómo se relacionan los lados de
dos triángulos semejantes, ¿cierto? Si nada de
esto te parece conocido, te invito a que revises
los videos sobre triángulos semejantes y criterios
de semejanza de triángulos en Khan Academy. Bien,
es momento de trabajar juntos. Sabemos que
en triángulos semejantes se cumple que:
a/m = b/n = c/ñ, es decir, la razón entre los
lados correspondientes es la misma. Además,
como sabemos que son semejantes, sus ángulos son
iguales entre ellos, es decir, se cumple que si
este es el ángulo alfa, entonces, por el teorema
anterior, el área A entre el área B = bc/nñ.
Estamos utilizando la idea del teorema anterior,
pero, dado que son semejantes, sabemos que
b/n = c/ñ, entonces, si utilizamos la expresión
que relaciona las áreas, tenemos que: el área
A entre el área B = bc/nñ, esto es lo mismo que
bb/nn, que es igual a b²/n². Ahora bien, podemos
usar la misma idea, es decir que b/n = c/ñ, pero
a la inversa, en lugar de sustituir b/n vamos a
sustituir c/ñ por b/n; entonces, tenemos que el
área A entre el área B = b•c/n•ñ = c•c/ñ•ñ, que
es igual a c²/ñ². Bien, ya tenemos dos de nuestras
expresiones que queríamos demostrar. Por último,
podemos decir que si a/m = b/n, y elevamos todo al
cuadrado, tenemos que a²/m² = b²/n², entonces el
área A entre el área B también es igual al lado
a² entre el lado m². Y ya está, hemos terminado
la demostración. Espero que haya quedado un poco
más clara la idea de que estos tres teoremas no
son arte de magia, se obtienen de las ideas de
área que definimos anteriormente. También espero
que te hayan ayudado a entender mejor estas
tres relaciones entre las áreas y los lados
entre triángulos. Eso es todo por este video,
nos vemos en el siguiente. Hasta la próxima.